so today we want to talk about the
difference between canned water or
plastic bottled water what would be
better okay
well let's first talk about plastic
bottles in general now it's made from a
certain chemical in plastic called
polyethylene terephthalate and there are
over 15,000 plastic bottles disregarded
every single second 80% of these end up
in landfill okay and it is biodegradable
but it takes a thousand years so your
great-great-great great-great-great
great-great great-great grandkids will
experience the benefit okay it's gonna
be a long time so on a yearly basis it
uses 17 million barrels of oil and ten
percent of this plastic ends up in the
ocean okay where it breaks down to a
certain degree and then the fish eat it
and then you eat the fish so it ends up
in your body and what's really ironic is
that the recycle rate is really really
low it's like nine point five percent
and it takes a lot more energy to
recycle these plastic bottles
now let's ship two cans okay I'm talking
about like when you're using like canned
water a hundred percent of it could be
recycled and it can be recycled forever
okay so you can keep recycling it over
and over and over it never wears out
with and you don't have to add anything
to it like you do with plastic and it
requires 95 percent less energy okay and
the recycle rate is 45 percent
so from an eco friendly standpoint it's
much much better okay now here the draw
box it does contain the chemical on the
inner coating called BPA well so does
plastics so they both contain this
chemical now there's some data that I
found which I don't know if it's
actually true or not but it says that
the curing process reduces this chemical
right here my thought is that the amount
that you're exposed to isn't quite high
and potentially it could be a problem if
you're just drinking all your water from
cans and by the way I recommend that you
just get a simple filter for your house
and start drinking mostly filtered water
and if you have the choice between
canned water and plastic go for the
canned
it's actually much better on the
environment thanks for watching
hey guys real quick I have a new healthy
keto eating plan for you just go to dr.
Berg comm it's right on the front page I
put a link down below download it it's
free check it out